pourtant travailleurs même que c'est un
homme que ce métier où je ne peux pas
l'arrêter n'y a rien à faire là
maintenant il est bien il va être obligé
de m'écouter et de prendre des vacances
mais c'est un programme ce garçon c'est
là je les réalise et la rage de vivre
il ne veut pas ça mais c'est vous qui le
disent mais c'est qu'on fasse bien vous
savez j'ai souvent arrêté les tournées
j'ai souvent été des galas seulement
quand après les longues et il était
tellement fatigué j'ai vu monsieur voulu
supprimer le canada n'a dit non c'est la
première que le canada joue absolument
d'aller ensuite comme j'ai vu on m'a
téléphoné pour me dire que quand elle
était très fatiguée je suis bon je vais
supprimer mars et juin pour le téléphone
me dit non absolument pas je veux
absolument aller à marseille
de nouveau il a gardé on regarde j'ai
gardé le gala grasset mais maintenant je
vais tout supprimer enfin je vais je
veux lui faire un planning normal ou
cloud pourra dormir manger même s'il
n'est pas content même s'il veut faire
ce métier il est obligé comme tous les
êtres humains à dormir et manger à se
reposer de temps en temps j'ai souvent
pendant des années des espèces de 2,2 de
trucs qui font chaud l'estomac qui monte
à la tête d' espèce d'étourdissements et
quand ils commencent à arriver en
général j'ai arrêté 4 5 secondes où
j'étais en faisant semblant d'avoir un
ennui de micro n'importe quoi et ça
passait des débuts d'étourdissements
celui là il a été j'étais je me souviens
près de l'orgue
j'étais sur l'orgueil il évolue d'un
coup je n'ai d'avoir fait trois quatre
mouvements de danse c'était juste la
finale du tout le genre je venais de
faire trop quatre pattes d'un gt vers
l'orgue
j'ai eu soudain repoussé et elle est
cette fois ci elle est montée quand même
et je suis tombé et enfin je suppose gp
rien vu je me souviens plus mais j'ai
joué j'ai toujours eu une saint tite
d'abord je veux j'arrive sur une scène
je chante je danse pendant une heure si
les gens sont contents je pourrais ces
deux heures s'ils le veulent je m'amuse
j'aime ça et je fais ça parce que
j'adore s'appuie sur mon avis ça
m'inspire rien bon je veux ça parce que
je ne veux que ça je suis un extrémiste
mais mais si on dit attention parce que
tes cachets et être une vente empêché
d'avoir ça alors je veux bien
un freiner et là je me rends bien compte
que j'exagérais de ce côté là que c'est
que c'est l'escaladé que je risque le
contraire et pas voir ce contraire je
vais me calmer